[Music]
straight ahead
on lawn crime daily the evidence
convicted wife killer scott peterson's
family says
he deserves a new trial over why a
reported conversation
between two inmates is now making
appellate arguments if anybody ever
deserved a new trial or to
walk out it would be him unsuspecting
motorists take the stand
against a former florida cop accused of
planting drugs
how body cam video unraveled more than a
hundred cases
it's not mine dude i swear to god it's
not mine
and three defendants in the armada
arbory case appear in federal court for
the first time
after hate crime charges are filed plus
a verdict in the killer roommate trial
an ohio man and missed the shooting but
does the jury believe it was in
self-defense yes it was my fault killing
him
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the california supreme court has
overturned scott peterson's death
sentence
and he's now arguing for a new trial in
the deaths of his wife lacey and their
unborn son
angenette levy is here to explain the
evidence his family and legal team says
could clear his name yeah brian peterson
has been on california's death row since
2005. the state's high court of course
vacated that death sentence
and said that a new sentencing hearing
had to be held
but a new trial could also be on the
horizon
if there was ever a case that needed to
be reversed on the guilt phase that's
the case
defense attorney mark garrigus
represented scott peterson at his trial
in 2004.
he thinks it's likely peterson will get
a new trial and cites evidence in
peterson's habeas petition
that could support his claims of
innocence including a 17-year-old
conversation between prison inmates
overheard by a corrections officer this
lieutenant aponte recording where
some inmates were talking about lacey
related to the burglary across the
street
which was astonishing to me never in my
career if i had anything
quite that outrageous whether it was
coincidental incidental or not
garrigus said information about that
call was not turned over by prosecutors
until the day peterson was convicted
peterson's petition says a lieutenant
aponte
recorded the prison call between two
brothers and then lost it
peterson claims one of the men said his
friend broke into a home in lacie
peterson's neighborhood the morning she
disappeared
and that he saw lacey after the time
prosecutors claimed she was killed
police had claimed the burglary happened
two days later on december 26th
i would think generally if you're going
to commit a burglary you're not going to
do it when the world is watching on the
day after christmas across the street
and mind you i've been there that's
we're not talking a large highway this
is a small residential street
16 years after peterson was convicted
his case
is getting a lot of attention i think if
people step back
and look at the evidence they're going
to see this crime isn't solved
2020 is taking an in-depth look at the
case this week
with interviews from peterson's
sister-in-law janie who's made it a
mission to collect information
she believes will exonerate peterson
there was information that i had
that nobody knew or heard amber fry the
woman with whom peterson was having an
affair and testified at his trial
is also in the special but the issue
that may win a new trial for peterson
has to do with juror rachelle niece
peterson's attorneys say she lied on her
questionnaire about being a victim of
domestic violence
she did not follow the judge's orders
she said basically said i'm here to get
justice
for for lacey and little man as she
called
connor now the california supreme court
sent this case back to the trial court
and ordered the court to look into these
alleged issues
with that juror rachelle niece peterson
meanwhile will be back in court
in june brian thanks internet
joining us today is civil rights
attorney jeff storms and terry austin
jeff late discovery handed over in
potential during misconduct
does that equal new trial in your eyes
you know
a lot of times it doesn't brian a new
trial is a very
difficult thing to obtain but what i
will say
is that you know obviously this is a
very factually detailed case
and the california supreme court has saw
something about it
that's raised its eyebrows so i think
that
there's going to be a lot of attention
placed on this case and
a lot of facts to sift through now terry
a new
trial but do you think that the new
facts will create a new result here
i don't brian i think the evidence in
the first trial was
overwhelming despite that most of it was
circumstantial i mean you have the fact
that
lacey peterson's body floated to shore
near where scott peterson was fishing
and that was no coincidence and then we
all know he had an affair
with amber fry and oftentimes that is
also a motive having said all of that
brian i do
think that if there is new evidence we
need to make sure that justice is done
and in fact that issue should be
determined one way or another
now angela what does the peterson
defense say about their chances
on a retrial you know they seem pretty
hopeful
in all of the public comments that
they've made they believe that there
were mistakes made
in this case i think it's important to
point out though that the california
supreme
court there were a number of issues
raised in this petition that scott
peterson's team filed with the high
court
and they they basically dismissed many
if not most of the issues he raised
but this issue with the juror that's
really come front and center
and mark aragus said that this juror
rachelle niece she was called strawberry
shortcake
by the media during the trial or after
the trial she was very flamboyant very
outspoken apparently she's written a lot
of
letters to scott peterson at san quentin
where he is on death row
so um her behavior has really indicated
to the defense team or they believe
that she was not impartial and that she
came in there into the deliberation room
with a a clear agenda yeah it seems that
the new
trial is the first battle that they've
kind of almost
laid some pretty good groundwork for the
question becomes when they do get that
new trial
what will the result be thank you evan
for your input and now to terry austin
with an update on the so-called
doomsday cult couple case terry brian
the defense is subpoenaing
a local reporter and a family member of
the defendants
ordering them to appear in court for the
next hearing
lori vallo and her husband chad dabell
are charged with concealing and
destroying
evidence while valo's children were
reported missing
authorities discovered the bodies of j.j
and tyler ryan
buried in shallow graves on daebel's
property east idaho
news journalist nate eaton along with
heather day bell
the wife of chad dabell's oldest brother
are ordered to
appear they're due in court on june 9
for a scheduling conference
it's not yet known why the defense is
subpoenaing either
of them be sure to tune in into long
crime network
for live coverage brian thanks terry
still ahead on law and crime daily ahmad
arbore's accused killers appear in
federal court
for the first time but first hear from
witnesses in the trial of a former cop
accused of planting drugs why they say
drugs found in their car
was not there before it was searched
next
[Music]
one by one victims took the stand
against zachary wester
the former florida deputy who they say
planted drugs in their car
did you end up agreeing to let him
search the car
at first i was assisting to i said you
want to search this car you search it
and you know
search all you want you know
sir why did you say that because uh
i know that's their gateway entry and i
knew
i knew my truck was clean i saw what
appeared to be a syringe sticking out
yeah okay whenever i went i looked
further pulled the seat apart
the syringe is actually in like a
plastic larger baggie
with a plastic container with a
substance in it that appears to be
an illegal narcotic do you know anything
about that
i do not these motorists from jackson
county florida have a similar story
they were all pulled over for a traffic
stop by former deputy zachary wester
that's not mine
do you use methamphetamine no
what is it that he just showed you mr
triggers a needle to have
full wrapped around it all right we
heard what you said
um just to be clear what was your
reaction
oh i'm shocked and
nervous trying to figure out what was
going on richard driggers is one of
those victims
drigger says the headlight on his car
was not working but couldn't afford to
fix it
wesser pulled him over then reported
smelling something suspicious
jurger says he complied with the search
of his car the next thing triggers knew
wester approached him with this i got to
figure out
why you have the loaded syringe and the
confidence yeah
you know what that means when it's
loaded that means you have stuff in it
yeah yes sir but it's not fun i promise
you
drinkers was arrested and booked in the
county jail many of the witnesses to
testify against the ex-cop
have one commonality possible
a rap sheet you've never used
methamphetamine i have in the past
that's been a long time like many others
drinkers pled guilty
i knew nobody was gonna believe it that
wasn't my stuff
why did you feel like no one was gonna
believe it because he's the cop
no sir it was my word against an officer
charges against driggers as well as
other witnesses were dropped
back with us as civil rights attorney
jeff storms and terry austin
jeff as i said earlier the alleged
victims in this case all seem to have
those
uh similarities that they have less of
ability to fight
back in court could wester have been
targeting them
well i think that's entirely likely
brian and we see that
all the time right i mean uh often if an
officer is going to engage in
intentional
in unlawful and proper conduct like they
did here
they try to pick the easiest target they
can right and typically that's someone
who has a prior history because that is
going to likely impact their credibility
right away if they have that prior
criminal history
and typically someone with lesser
economic means
because they're less likely to be able
to hire
an attorney or have access to uh the
type of
experts or legal defense that they might
need to challenge an
officer so they certainly look for
individuals who are
on unequal footing with them in the
system
yeah and i have to admit as a public
defender i've been here and done that
where
your client is faced with take a
misdemeanor in time
served or sit in jail for another two
three months where you can lose your
housing lose your work lose all of this
and they'd rather take the 200
ticket and the misdemeanor to get out
then fight the case and i think that's
what's going on here
terry the defense is pointing to the
investigation and that the alleged
victims
could be lying but with video like this
that we're seeing in this case
is that a losing battle i do think it's
a losing battle i mean if you take a
look at
wester the evidence against him is
damning his
habit the way he does each and every one
of these individuals
is all the same he's picked these
individuals as jeff said
who have a prior history or who may not
have the funds
to hire an attorney and then he plants
these drugs upon them
and then you know they are drug users
from the past but it's always the
distance past
and he doesn't want to give them an
opportunity basically
to just go on a minor infraction and all
of these infractions
were very very minor one had a cracked
windshield
as you heard in the clip there was a you
know light that was
out and then he says can i search the
vehicle and of course they may not know
their rights and they go ahead and let
him search because
they don't think there's anything there
so i think that
all of this together he does this each
and every time and the thing
that i think is most offensive is he is
in a position of authority and he's
abusing that authority
and i think it's horrible and i hope
that in fact they do find him guilty
yeah
and i know this kind of crazy argument
that i see in minnesota that uh that
you're practicing in jeff
that some of these minor frac
infractions they should just be mailed
in or
checked in uh if you have the person's
license plate rather than these stops
because
this is a problem they're seeing not
just in this case but around the country
thank you both for your input coming up
on law and crime daily the verdict is in
for the case of the dismembered roommate
plus the latest in the mod arbory case
how much evidence prosecutors say they
have against the accused killers
next
[Music]
we're back three men charged in the
shooting death of ahmad armory are
pleading not guilty to new federal
charges
aubry was gunned down while he was out
jogging in february 2020.
state prosecutors charged father and son
gregory and travis mcmichael with malice
murder
a third man william rhodey brian is
charged with boxing aubry inn while
filming the incident
they're now also facing federal charges
for interference with rights
and attempted kidnapping both mcmichaels
are also charged with using guns to
inflict violence just that
if he would have stopped the three men
were arraigned in federal court in
georgia on tuesday
they asked to be appointed public
defenders prosecutors say they're
prepared to tone over one terabyte worth
of discovery
including fbi interviews cell phone
records and search warrants
you know should we been chasing me i
don't know
the defendants are due in state court on
wednesday for a motions hearing
here to break down a terabyte worth of
info in the mcmichaels and brian
indictment
is civil rights attorney jeff storms and
co-host terry austin
terry how do you feel the charges fit
when you know all about the case or what
you know about the case
were they undercharged overcharged or do
these charges fit the ax
i definitely think the charges fit the
act i mean if you
look at the video there's no question
that the father and son
should be charged with malice murder and
in georgia that just simply means it was
deliberate and it was intentional
and the fact that they chased him down
that was deliberate that was intentional
they're also charged with using guns to
inflict violence
and they used guns and they did inflict
violence
and roddy bryan i mean he's being
charged with boxing
you know aubry in and he did just that
we see that on the video so i think all
of the state charges are actually
accurate
and the federal charges are accurate as
well because
they did deprive him of his
constitutional rights no question
about it and attempted kidnapping i
think that makes sense because that's
what they tried to do so i think the
charges
are exactly right now jeff as a civil
rights attorney what does it mean to you
to see these federal charges
in 2021 with a terabyte worth of
evidence
you know it shows us that uh prosecutors
across the country are becoming
less afraid of pursuing these charges
you know
these types of charges require uh you
know
showing that there was intent based upon
race you know in this particular
interest or uh instance
and prosecutors don't like to lose
right and so uh these types of difficult
claims are the types of claims that a
lot of prosecutors often wouldn't bring
but now in the current environment where
we see derrick chauvin convicted right
of second-degree murder
i think it's provided more courage for
prosecutors and the terabyte of evidence
shows us they're throwing their efforts
more deeply and fully
into this because they really believe
they can
and need to win yeah i can see that
there definitely may be a belief that
these cases can be proven i know they
they kind of steer away from hate crime
charges
or those involving race gender or other
uh protected class i think you're right
hopefully we'll see
more of this in the future when we come
back the verdict did michael dixon
murder dismember then burn his
roommate's remains
we will we reveal what the jury
determined on the other side of this
break welcome back
after just three hours of deliberation a
jury found an ohio man guilty
of killing dismembering and burning his
roommate
michael dixon was facing 13 charges for
the murder and dismemberment of his
roommate
jim whitaker dixon took the stand in his
own defense
and actually admitted to shooting
whitaker but said it was in self-defense
dixon claimed whitaker pointed a gun at
him first trying to stop dixon from
leaving with his daughter
he said he burned the body because he
was scared of getting caught
but on cross-examination the prosecutor
asked about allegations
dixon was sexually assaulting his 18
year old daughter the only charge he was
found not guilty of
you were having sex with your daughter
melody weren't you no
so when melody told that to law
enforcement she was lying
approach yeah thank you michael so
when keith strickland testified that
you and your daughter would go to bed
together and there would be one bed down
there he was
he was wrong he was lying okay
so with respect to him saying that there
were sex noises coming from the basement
um that would be not be true that's not
true
so according to you james said
um that he was going to shoot you is
that right that's what you said
and then you decide to go and get your
gun yep
but you could have left right i could
have yes
okay and you decided not to correct i
wasn't leaving my daughter there
but james wasn't threatening you or your
daughter he was just threatening you
according according to your words yep
prosecutors then asked an offender about
allegedly trying to cover up the murder
like writing a fake suicide note in the
victim's name
my daughter showed it to keith
strickland you didn't show it to him
nope
that's nothing that james wrote was it i
don't think so i don't know
i didn't write it defense counsel asked
you about
your story being the truth now
remember that just asked you that well
there are some things
you said now that have been the first
time you said them you realize that
right
yes and
why would you leave officers on a wild
goose chase for this jawbone that you
never had
i don't know you lived in james's house
for about
20 days after uh you killed him yes
and you sold his stuff didn't you on tv
yes
you didn't sell this gun i'm buying a
gun yes
all right let's bring in jeff and terry
one last time jeff convicted of all
charges
but the sexual assault of his daughter
is that the verdict you saw coming
well i think an acquittal on anything
was a little surprising although i
didn't get to watch every piece of the
evidence but
certainly after the testimony he
provided in court
the convictions that we have were not
surprising at all
now terry seems like dixon's testimony
in his own case
didn't help him sometimes we say as
defense attorneys you can
either as a defense attorney lose a case
or the prosecution
won the case where do you think this
case fell
i think it was both i think it was a
strong prosecution and i think it was a
very
weak defense listen if you just even
think about the fact that
dixon lied so many times the biggest lie
was
about how in fact whitaker died first he
said
oh i don't know where he is then he said
oh whitaker left then he said
well maybe he committed suicide then he
said yes okay well i killed him
then the other big issue obviously is
that he covered it up that's
consciousness
of guilt the fact that he burned the
body it's just
showing that he obviously is trying to
cover everything up
he got rid of the individual's property
i mean if you're selling the property
clearly you want to just make sure he's
not in existence at
all and he hid the guns so i think that
the prosecution had a lot to work with
but here's one other thing brian when
dixon got on that stand and he kept
saying
yep yep nope nope it
sounded to the jury in my opinion like
he really didn't care that he was cold
and callous and i think that's why he
got the conviction on the highest counts
yeah presentation
on the stand as well as that cover-up uh
in just like 10 seconds real quick jeff
do you think that cover-up really hurt
the case
for dixon the cover-up always
hurts in the case i've seen this try to
be done before
it never works or hardly ever works yeah
i mean as the saying goes sometimes it's
not the crime but the cover-up
jeff terry thank you very much and thank
you for joining us here at long crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you